[Music]
okay so if you
if your sound is poor quality the hosts
from the webinar have suggested that you
log out and log in again and that's
something you could try if you are
having difficulties with yourself
right i think it's that time that we
we got started
so please do continue to ask your
questions and i will try and pick up as
many of those as i can either as we go
through or towards the end of the
presentation
um there's also
um an option i i will see that you've
you've asked a question it's like upon
the participants or so hopefully i will
get around to answering those as well
so thank you for joining this corporate
for those of you who don't know me my
name is elizabeth harin
i write the blog a girl's guide to
project management and i also approach
project managers
as well as working as a project manager
in the healthcare industry
in the uk
i'm often asked about the differences
between the different qualifications
that are available on the market and
that is what this webinar is going to
cover today
we are going to cover a brief
introduction to pov
and then we're going to look at capm and
prince2 individually and then we'll look
at comparing those as well afterwards
so like i say if you have got questions
please type the inbox i'll try and
answer as many as i can
let's start with an overview of the
different qualifications that we're
looking at today
first let's talk about pmp project
management professional qualification
as i'm sure many of you know it's the
premium qualification offered by pmi
which is the project management
institute it's globally recognized and
in order to be able to apply for it you
need to have some level of experience as
working as a project manager
so
the prerequisites for taking that
qualification for making your
application are either a secondary
degree which is a high school diploma an
associate's degree or the global
equivalent
seven and a half
thousand hours of leading and directing
projects which sounds like quite a lot
and 35 hours of project management
education which equates to about
a full-time working week
of training courses or you don't have to
take them as a single blog
alternatively if you don't meet those
requirements you can still apply for the
pnp with a four-year degree and only
four and a half thousand hours of
leading directing projects although you
do still need that 35 hours of project
management education in order to be able
to if your for your application to be
considered by pmi
now the last data i've got for how many
credential holders there are it
comes from the latest edition of pmi
today which is the members newsletter
and that is
quite a lot of people who have got this
kind of credentials worldwide
the certified associates in project
management is another tmi qualification
again globally recognized it hasn't been
around as long as some of the other
qualifications
and
globally the the data again from the
july disappear today says there's 28 000
28.5 000 certificate holders around the
world
there are um different prerequisites for
this qualification you don't have to
have experience working as a project
manager in order to put forward an
application for the capm something
different
but you do need other prerequisites so
you've got two options firstly you need
to have either a secondary degree
or 23 hour and 23 hours of project
management education that gets you round
the work experience
requirements
or
you can have that secondary degree and
1500 hours of project experience so you
you either drop the project management
education requirement or you drop the
work experience requirements so it's
slightly
easier
uh there's a slightly lower requirement
for people to um
to apply for that one
right i've had a request to speak more
slowly i'm sorry about that
i will try to do that thank you
for reminding me
the third qualification we're going to
look at today is
prince 22
that stands for project in controlled
environments
and it's a method so it steps you
through the processes for managing a
project
and because of that if a direct
comparison with the credentials from pmi
is difficult and actually probably quite
unwise to do they're not qualifications
that you can
[Music]
it's not a qualification that you can
easily compare with what pmi have to
offer
however it's a process-based method
designed specifically for effective and
efficient management from beginning to
end again it's globally recognized
you don't need experience in order to be
able to
to go ahead and take the take the course
or take the exam
and it might help to explain here how
the original version of prince2 came
about perhaps something that you may be
less familiar with than pmi
qualifications
so the original version was created in
1989 by the central computer and
telecommunications agency of the uk
so it's a way to it was started as a way
to specifically address the common
causes of project failure and it quickly
became the uk standard project
management methodology
it was popular but it was soon
considered too large too unwieldy too
rigid only appropriate for these
projects
and as a result they needed to
do something differently
we what we needed
to do was to make sure it was more
suitable for a wider variety of
of projects and it's been updated
several times since then
um
in fact today we're using the 2009
version of prince2 and this year they've
also learned welsh attention to agile
credentials
so the other major thing to understand
about prince2 is that actually it's a
family three qualifications
the foundation practitioner and
professional again this is why a direct
comparison with either the atm
or
pmp is difficult
prince2 foundation is the basic
certification level and it covers basic
physical terminology and methodology
it's ideal for project managers aspiring
project managers
and staff of inventors play a key role
but it doesn't test how you can apply
that knowledge
the next certification level is also
designed for project managers and the
project team
but it shows that the individual has
sufficient knowledge of how to use and
customize prince2
in the
in the real project environment so
that's the practitioner level
and from the principle professional
level which is the highest level of
certification it tests your knowledge
and ability across all the stages of the
project life cycle
so not everyone who works in project
management or who is appreciative
practitioner
goes ahead and reaches this level
because it requires a two and a half day
assessment at a residential assessment
centre
so
statistics again very difficult to
compare because the
the axle ups who are the the owners of
this product
are less transparent about publishing
their data about pmi
they say that currently over a million 2
exams have been taken all across the
globe
but you should also bear in mind by
looking at that number that people can
let their principal registration expire
so the exam taken figure probably
includes people who took the exam and
then have not
not been registered
and we'll look at the ongoing
requirements for making sure your
credentials stay
and stays relevant for pmp to see aps
and prince2 later
there's another global management global
project management at crestingbody that
we won't talk about today but it's still
worth knowing that it
and that is ipma
that's the international project
management association and it accredits
national bodies
in the uk it's the association subject
management the atm in the us it's the
american society for the advancement of
project management and in india it's
project management associates so it's uh
it accredits local
local body
and at the end of 2014 according to
their website there are approximately a
quarter of a million icma certificate
holders worldwide and they work on a
competence-based professionally assessed
certification it's a four-level system
there's an awful lot about it and a
comparison of the ipma qualifications
against prints to
the atm and pmp on their website their
website is ipma.ch
but
a discussion um
around that is out of scope of our
webinar today
so let's look now at the differences
between pmp and principles
so slightly from a perspective of
training
there's lots of different ways that you
can take training and it's something
that you need to to really look at your
own personal learning style to think of
what would be best for you
for pmp lots of options are around
including self-study
classroom based courses
online courses led by an instructor
online courses that are self-paced
learning
um personally i think that it's a good
idea to look for a blend of multiple
different learning styles or learning
delivery mechanisms i think that would
help you
get a better understanding of your
training material and of course you've
got the option of working with your
colleagues to create study groups
to look at the pnp exam it's a four-hour
exam it has 200 multiple choice
questions
it's a computer-based exam so you do
have to go to a local exam center in
order to be able to deliver that um
to be able to take that exam
breakthrough is slightly different
um
it's a classroom-based
classroom-based course is probably the
most common way of doing it but you can
use online materials as well you can
also study and just turn up
for the printer to
exam at the end and something that
is definitely possible especially if you
live along a test center but it is
something that is rare
um there's a couple of questions that
i've come in i'll address here
i've had it in the pmp exam 25 questions
or test questions is this true yes it is
they often put in
they do put in test questions
they are not assessed for your exam but
they are
used to make the group of exam questions
more broader more wide and so
it's a way of making sure that they have
constantly refreshed up-to-date
questions that are pitched at the right
level
but they won't
they won't um
count towards your mark
and in this slide i'm comparing
a pnp with princeton foundation and
practitioner we won't be talking today
about the
the professional option of a
the assessment center i think that's
something that
it's still quite a new option and it's
not an option for most people
so this exam here though is um
does relate
to the principle practitioner exam
you've got
it
most people would opt to do if you're
going to do a classroom course
and most people in the uk i can talk my
local experience opt to do a combined
foundation and practitioner course in a
classroom it's instructure-led course
and you take the foundation exam on the
wednesday and if you're successful you
can stay in the classroom for further
study on thursday and take the
practitioner exam on friday
so
there are also opportunities to do it on
online learning and weekend courses
as well i just do examples
um
so for the foundation exam again it's
multiple tests
it's 75 questions of the paper and there
are five questions that are trial
questions
there's 35
marks that are required to pass out of
70 available marks so that's a 50 pass
rate
the foundation exam is 60 minutes and
it's closed which means you can't take
your manuals or notes into the exam
which is the same as for the pmp exam
for the principal practitioner exam
it's multiple choice but it's a style of
multiple choice called objective testing
so there are eight questions with 10
question items per question
and it gets quite complicated there's a
long scenario to read
and they call the style objective
testing
it's a two and a half hour exam
um but you don't get any extra reading
time and you need to take
the 80 points available and you need 44
marks or wall to pass
so that's a puzzle mark of 55 percent
the difference if that one between pfe
is and the foundation exam is that you
can take your official 22 manual into
the exam as a reference
so the big difference there in what i've
said is that the 2 exams are quite clear
about their pulse rate
pmi are more kg about exactly what
percentage is required to pass
they don't publish a pass mark
but commentators and training providers
tend to agree that you need to be
looking at routinely getting 75
in your practice exam in order to be
sure passing
okay
so that's a bit of an overview between
asp and prince2
let's look at the framework and some of
the other ongoing requirements for it
um the pnp is based on the pinbop guide
project management board in knowledge
which is currently in the fifth edition
it's a standard that describes rules
processes and practices but alone it
won't tell you how to do a project
it's more of a collection of knowledge
guidelines and best practices
it's based on five process groups
so that
they are
initiating planning
executing
monitoring and controlling and closing
there are 10 knowledge areas covered in
the book
covered in the pinbot guide and they are
integration management
scope management
time management
product management
quality management
human resource management communications
management
risk management
procurement management and stakeholder
management
so prince2 is a project management
method
it helps you implement the knowledge
practically so you could actually use
the pinworld guide and the principal
manual together
they are complementary you don't have to
limit yourself to using
one or the other
because as well as a standard you also
need a method to be able to implement
the project successfully
the framework for 2 is about 7
principles 17
and 7 processes
the 7 principles are
continued business justification that's
all and business case
learning from experience
defining your roles and responsibilities
managing those stages
merging by extension focusing on
products
and management sections sorry focus on
products and tailoring disputes and
project design
the themes
that underpin printed two are the
business case organization
quality
plan
risk
change
and progress
and the processes there are
seven impressions this is in the moving
foods too
they cover starting up a project
initiating a project
managing a stage boundary is the
transition between one phase and another
closing project
controlling a stage managing product
delivery
and directing a project so you can see
that while they might use different
words actually there's a lot of common
themes there around planning quality
change
managing the world
so you will find that it is it after all
there are only so many ways you can
manage projects um
so you'll have to see a lot of common
themes come through both of them
for the photos that have ongoing
requirements for the project manager
for pmp you are required to get
professional development units every
three years and you have to submit those
to prove that you're getting them
there's lots of ways to earn
professional development units so if you
don't leave it to the last minute then
it really is not difficult to maintain
your your qualifications
one thing to know there is that the pdu
requirements are changing this year in
december so if you are looking to get
your pmp
then you should look out for those
changes coming into practice
and in fact if your pmp certification
expires
on or after the 1st of december
2017 then it's the new pdu model that
you need to the working tool
so that's going to affect everybody
who's going for certification now even
if you might qualify before december
when you
you still it hasn't actually changed
that much you do still need to get 60
cdus but the way they're split and
categorized is the main difference
the change has happened because pmi are
aligning
their continuous professional
development requirements
with the talent triangle they've
developed so they've changed the
categorization to be more relevant to
the three talent triangle areas which
are technical project management
leadership and strategic business
management
to maintain your qualification as a
registered principal practitioner you
have to re-register within three to five
years of your original certification so
for the person kumar who asked is it
possible to extend the certificate
validity of validity for further three
years yes you can
you take your re-registration exam and
you will re-register as a substitution
practitioner
for
another three to five years and you can
continue doing that
um the
[Music]
examination format for that it's a
one-hour exam it's three questions there
are ten items questions again it's a 55
percent pass mark and you can take in
your project management uh manual or
institute manual as long as it's the
official side so
it's something you've got between three
and five years to do that exactly again
if you know it's coming it is something
that you can plan for if you want to
take a one-day training course in order
to refresh your skills do that and take
these out
and ask them
um
location wise those qualifications are
unknown globally
the emp originated in the us
it's now known throughout the world
there are 274 pmi chapters
and in 205 countries so that gives you
an indication of how widespread
pmi membership is although you don't
need to be a member in order to take
certificates
prince2 as we've seen originated in the
uk is known globally it's particularly
strong in europe it's particularly known
for its use within government
um that is the
end of our comparison of 22 and here
people actually will come back to
some of those questions later on and now
i want to look at the differences
between copm and principles
so let's
have a quick look through those i won't
go over all of this
again
uh cfpm training is offered in much the
same way as pnp training
the main difference really is that it's
a shorter exam it's only 150 multiple
choice questions
and we've covered the 2 training and the
options for the exam earlier so i'm
going to cover that again now
the framework for capn is exactly the
same as pmp so you will be studying from
the same material
the main difference is the depth of
questions in the exam
capm will only test your knowledge of
what is important guide it's also not
accredited in the same way
pmp credential scheme is accredited by
the american national standards
institute nc
against the international organization
for standardization so it's against iso
the
2 foundation exam has very similar goals
and then it just tests the knowledge of
concepts set out in the handbook
foundation level aims to measure whether
a candidate would be able to act as an
informative member of the project
management team using institute method
within a project environment
and to this end they have to be able to
show that they understand the principles
and the technologies of the method much
about much as we would have to do with a
capm exam
at a practitioner level
princeton practitioner tries to assess
whether a candidate could actually apply
the knowledge so in that respect it's
testing something slightly different to
the capn example
and there are ongoing requirements again
with that
you also have to
retake your copf exam every five years
there's no
um
requirements to take pdus you just sit
the exam every five years and with 22
mvc uv registers between three and five
years after your returning certificate
same location and background
so if someone's asked the question why
is the pmt exam so difficult to pass and
i'd have to say i don't think it is i
think if you put the time and effort
into studying and you understand the
concepts within the book and you take
practice exams and you understand that
skin what guide is not your only source
of knowledge that you look also at
things like the code of ethics
i think if you prepare for it any exam
is straightforward and after
i do know that people find it difficult
to do
it these styles questions can be
frustrating and the my best tip for you
is to take lots of practice success and
to work with people who have done it and
who understand how the questions are
structured you may well have complete
knowledge of the book and still not
perform well in the in the exam
situation
so hopefully
that answers that question there
so those are the main differences
between cops prince2
so now let's look at probably a big
decision for many project managers is
that they've decided that
they are
going to go
with um
a pmi credential
and
they've got to use pmp and caps
so let's look at whether or not the cipm
or pmp is potentially the right option
the
the training is the same the examination
seems slightly different i think it's
comfortability probably clear about that
the framework that they're working on is
the same as the main
um
the requirements for ongoing
qualifications we've taken the looks of
those as well so you've got the pdu
requirements pmp which is the continuous
professional development the capm you
just do the exam
the main difference between these two
qualifications from pmi
is that
the pmp is aimed at experienced project
managers
you have to have this come back to the
prerequisites i mentioned earlier you
have to have
some degree of managing projects before
you can put forward an application to go
for the pnp exam
so just to recap on that to do the capm
you don't need to have the experience if
you've got some training so you can have
your secondary degree your classical
diploma you've worked global equivalent
associates degree and 23 hours of
project management education which can
be achieved
through any formal boot as long as you
can evidence that you achieve that
or you can skip the project management
courses and apply if you can prove that
you've had 1500 hours of project
experience to go alongside your degree
the
pmp does require you to have
professional experience in managing
projects and you will have to evidence
it on your application so if you got it
15 years ago in a previous job you need
to be able to contact those people so
that they can verify that you actually
did it and act as witnesses to your
experience
and you're looking to prove that you've
got your legacy degree and seven and a
half thousand hours of leading and
directing projects plus your 35 hour
budget management training
or you can a higher level degree or
four-year degree with only four and a
half thousand hours of leading and
directing projects with 35 hours of
project management education
um a question here about
if you don't have managerial experience
which qualifications should you go for
if indeed it's worth going for any
qualification at all
if you don't have project management
experience then i think all it is just
all these qualifications will be
uh tricky to achieve
pmp it will not be possible because you
will not be able to evidence that you
have project management experience
and the prince2 exam will be difficult
because it assumes there is some well
you don't have to prove you have project
management experience before you go into
the
classroom or before you sign up for an
online course
you'll find the concepts make a lot more
sense if you've worked in a project
environment
apm doesn't require you to
have project management
experience but you will have had to do
some degree of training so that you've
got some knowledge of what project
management is all about before you go
ahead and frankly if you've never worked
on a project and you try to read a
pinboard guide i think you can struggle
in terms of whether you have to be a
project manager whether your managerial
experience has to be in leading projects
um i would say no i would say you do not
have to be the person in charge of the
entire project in order to go for any of
these qualifications
as long as you've had responsibilities
for project tasks or perhaps a work
stream
or in a test environment having
experience of managing the test phases
of projects you will probably find that
you can justify your experience
adequately to be able to go for any of
these qualifications
so is it worth um
is it like the impact
it all study takes up time and it takes
money
in order to go ahead to
study and give up your spare time to
learn something new and the stress of
taking an exam
so let's look at that
oops all right we've gone too far
indications on your job
um
there is some argument who's saying that
qualification
will help you in your career
so there's some data that's been put
together from
uh it has some people indeed which says
that project managers with pmps are 18
more than their peers
this is i mean it's a really interesting
figure but i'm not sure that if i would
get an 18 percent pay rise in my current
jobs if i turned up one day and told my
manager that i was now pmp
i think it's more likely that you'll see
that increase over time and as a result
of earning promotions
based on your ability to do your job
well and a credential that helps you
understand the project's environment the
context in which projects work
how to view better and deliver a more
successful outcome all of these will
contribute to career success which will
then earn you the money perhaps you
might need to change jobs in order to
uh to see any increase in batteries but
i think um
statistically it's interesting to see
that people with credentials tend to
consider it's also an excellent
negotiating chip when you come to have
your annual appraisal any qualification
that you have does show that you're
dedicated to project management as a
career and that you are prepared to
improve your skills
through study and through hard work
pmi did some research in 2013 as they
produced a talent gap report which said
there are going to be four and a half
million jobs created in project
management by 2020
and that is really good news if you're
wondering whether project management is
a long-term profession and whether you
will find work commentary with the
qualifications that you have then
achieved
now i'm skeptical about a lot of surveys
but with this one i do actually agree
with pmi
my own reading and research shows that
the global economy is changing
we're moving towards more and more
knowledge work and project-based work
and it makes sense that project managers
will find more opportunities
and that work that's also the case for
project managers who do not have the job
sites for project manager and promising
more and more people who are managing
projects within their job
but who are perhaps not given the title
of project manager within their
organisation
in that same study pmi concluded that
the project management industry is set
to grow by 6.6 trillion u.s dollars by
and i think what they mean by that is
that there will be more project based
work
for me it's another indication that
companies are investing more in projects
therefore again it's logical to conclude
that they will need project managers
either people who have the job title of
project manager project coordinator
project leader or people who simply have
the skills and experience to be able to
lead projects as part of their day just
a different area
so
the additional jobs created the
additional
investment in project management
assume that you don't really need a
credential
but if you want to compete with people
who do those jobs
then it does make a sense to get a
qualification that's relevant to your
career stage
your industry
education
it is perfectly possible to have a
successful project management career
without qualifications
but taking the time to earn and achieve
a certificate offers you i think a
number of worthwhile benefits
it it helps you
be equipped
and it will normally help you improve
your speed efficiency
it should get you more positive outcomes
at work
it will save your employees time and
money which is a good thing because you
will be more efficient
um if you could prove that it might end
up in a promotion for you
for me personally i managed a lot of it
projects i managed
mainly care i used to work in finance
services method i go to work financial
services um
financial services technology projects
but the biggest
difference it made to me is to increase
my confidence and competition so if you
are more confident in your ability you
will much more likely be a success but
obviously
that might not have the same effect for
you i'm just speaking personally but i
think
every time you complete a project you're
learning more and the more confidence
you have and these qualifications help
you achieve that level of confidence
being generally the best within job
finally if you find yourself in the
market for a new job having a
certificate will improve your
marketability it will put your name up
there
it makes you
able to play with the other candidates
on a level playing field and it may will
help you learn the job faster
easily it might help you keep your job
longer if your company goes through a um
exercise where some people leave or
their labor doesn't and they're looking
at people and trying to keep their talk
talent
okay i'll just pick up a couple of other
questions that have come in
uh one question here i've heard that
prince2 is easy as a pmp and it is of
less value than pmp is that true
in my experience i would say printed two
as an exam is easier than pmp
i would say value is a subjective thing
and
it
its value is what it is to the people
who are assessing it in the uk
code 2 is a de facto standard you may
not find many project managers who
expect to go following their career
without it however you'll also find a
small proportion of people with pmp and
that value by their employer so you need
to decide what value means to you and
your employer and your industry
and to do that i would recommend you
look at drivers in your area or your
the area that you want to work and look
at what they're asking for because if
nobody's asking for prints too then it's
not worth your will to take that
qualification
if everybody's asking for the apm then
that's probably if you want a job that's
probably the qualification that you
should go through
however i do not think it's possible to
say that one qualification has more
value than another because it is so much
dependent on what your employer wants
and whether you want to learn from
standard or whether you want to learn
method
so that's um
i know it hasn't answered um
i haven't given you definitive answer
but it's the truth
um why is pnp example just past i've
asked that one comparison to 52.
uh i would actually say the 22 questions
are harder the the 52 exam style
is a scenario
and an awful lot of reading to do they
are objective testing questions which
are which seems like they define trick
use multiple questions with multiple
options it's not at all their structure
of exam as pmp
so obviously if you study well you can
get your arrival from exam practice is
the key
um
does 52 and pmp do they complement each
other do you have to choose
you do not have to choose between them i
would still say this comes back to what
you find valuable in your job to me
there isn't really any options there
isn't really any value in taking you
that patient qualifications that are not
going to help you in your career so you
need to consider
how do your company work
does your company use sensitive
methodology or does it follow a response
methodology or does it follow a tmp
um
a psp approach
you can look at that by asking questions
you can consider the qualifications that
your peers have and if you are looking
to make a decision about what
qualifications you want to put all your
content into if you are immature in your
project management organization and you
haven't taken this decision yet then
it's worth looking at both standards and
assessing them against what you wanted
to do
because it's impossible to say that for
your company in your environment this is
the best option because there are
multiple
there's a module there's even more
options than what we've discovered here
today um because there's the ipma
qualifications as well and there are
other organizations people
there are other certificates that you
can get
um
so i
i think look at the interview okay
i will come back i see that there's more
questions coming in i
will um
will come back and answer those in a
second just a couple more points that i
wanted to make
and as you know this webinar sponsored
by cynthia and i have never worked in
las vegas they are a training provider
and examination centre they're
accredited and approved and recognized
by globally known names like
pmi and access uh apmg cfa institute
scott
aft tv iida and others as well
they are trusted by fortune 500
companies as a learning provider for
career growth and training and they've
trained over 4 000 professionals
worldwide they do have pmp and 62
certification training in the classroom
and almost their disabled
capm training is available online and
they also have an all-in-one project
management course package which includes
those three courses and some other ones
in that style at 99 government
um so it's worth
looking around at the different training
options that you've got available to you
either online if that suits your
location letter or locally
the bottom line really is
that i've asked this question a lot what
qualification can i take and i
uh on this webinar i find it difficult
to give you personalized advice and
there's so many of you but the bottom
line is you need to think about what you
want from your career and you need to
think about what
um
your employer or your future employer is
going to expect you to have you to do
some search of your of your own
uh i'll go through now and look at
some of the
other questions that come in hopefully
i'll get back to answering those
can you use two weeks to prepare for the
pmp exam
i would not recommend it
you probably could if you had two solid
weeks to prepare and it was all you
wanted to do during those weeks then i
would not put it past you if you're
dedicated you
probably managed
i would say however there is an awful
lot of material and if you are
approaching the pinpoint guys for the
very first time
yeah keep yourself longer
as there's a question here about
when you're not experienced in project
management how will the apm help you
it will help you be able to organize
your work more effectively and it will
help you
do the projects that you are working on
if you don't have the experience
it might help you get a job where you
can get some experience
will you be able to take pmp later when
you've got to experience yes of course
you can
taking any of these qualifications does
not mean that you're shutting doors for
the future you can take none of them or
all of them all at the same time or over
a period of several years
and
your career goals will change so you may
want to start off with 22 foundation or
catn something similar
and
move on when you have more experience to
appreciate practitioner or professionals
or pmp
here if there's any other questions
um
so
there are agile project management
certificates as well we haven't talked
about today
i
would have to say that the
language
of both pinpoint guide and the sensitive
handbook
don't lend themselves to agile
principles brought out an agile
credential an adjust certificate this
year which addresses that gap and
aligned some of the agile vocabulary
with the prince2 method
i would say you can still work in an
agile environment and use pinball
approaches
agile doesn't mean you don't do any
other project management you will still
need to be able to apply another rigor
management to your agile software
development on your agile whatever it is
development that you are doing
um
if you work in a purely agile
environment and you
if you're working with
you might want to consider the pnp is
really the right thing for you to do
first there might be other relevant
qualifications that
that suit your environment better
however pmp is certainly
of there that will just could help and
the same with with either prince2
officer you would find useful processes
and standards
approaches to getting work done that
will help you in another environment
um in order to pass the pmp exam how
many questions does one have to answer
correctly
there is no published
uh benchmark on that my advice would be
you need to be taking
practice exams and getting 75 in order
to give yourself confidence that you can
clear the exam
uh let's have a look
at some of these
how will your prior pm experience be
validated
if you
are not currently working
that's fine
as long as you can prove that you have
had the experience
and you will be able to register for the
pmp exam
the
question there is can you prove this so
that might need to come from
testimonials from your previous employer
references
you can use project management education
from many years ago several years ago as
long as you can prove it so it's
probably worth getting a handbook or the
application form
and going through
the prerequisites and having a look to
see whether or not you could evidence
based on what you can prove and the
people you are still in contact with
to see whether or not you can meet those
requirements
is there negative marketing in the pmp
exam i don't believe so
i've highlighted already the exam
differences between princeton foundation
and practitioner
the international development
organizations discriminate between p and
p and
individuals during hiring
that's not a question that
i don't know is the answer i can't
imagine that international development
organizations as a vlog
would discriminate between pmp or since
two i would imagine some might prefer
one some might prefer other
um i know that's probably not the answer
that you were hoping for but
unfortunately it's impossible to say for
oil and gas defense too so healthcare do
pmp
it just is truly not that simple and my
best advice to you is to research the
companies the industry that you want to
work in
local to your country you can begin
there on country specific differences
so for example in a uk government job if
i wanted to work in the philippine
service in the uk
i would be expected to get
uh principles i would find it very
difficult to work without that however
for
a u.s government job that's certainly
not the case
and in fact for a u.s government job i
would be saying look at something that
gives you background in earned value
because a lot of government contracts
rely on you being able to to demonstrate
your own value skills there
let's have a look and see if
any others
um
is there always a requirement of contact
us how do you gain those if you decide
to do sub study
you have you can
choose to self study with
materials that have been
prepared by
registered education providers pmi has a
list of people they accredit
and you can
download certificates generally you go
through an online program or you will
use their materials
they will give you a test and then they
will give you a certificate
they
self-study alone
will not qualify you for your 35 hours
of contact for your pmp certification
so
you need to have that it needs to be 35
hours of formal project management
education you don't have to do that in a
classroom but just reading the pinball
guide doesn't count you can't use that
as your 35 hours towards your 35 hours
of formal project management education
is to be done
with a recognized training provider
okay i think that's uh we're approaching
our of time i think i've asked the
majority
of questions that i can see there
um i'd just like to say thank you very
much for
coming
um
i appreciate all the questions it's
quite hard to keep up with them as
they've been coming in at i hope i've
managed to get through a lot of them
today
and
if i can i will try to answer any other
welcome on my blog in the weeks to come
so thank you very much for your
participation today in this webinar and
i hope you've managed to
answer some of your questions about the
certifications available to you as a
project manager
okay
you